where can they find you you know the
usually at a brothel but you know I'm
usually a patron so there's that that's
good you're like beyond sister I am
exactly yeah
what is up reject nation I'm Anita Starr
and with me is John Humphrey of the real
rejects what he said what he said the
needed star check her out on the YouTube
you guys know if you we're gonna talk
about some TV today as a matter of fact
yeah you found American Horse turn I am
NOT what is that
sterling you chess alright I have seen
everything that's on Netflix
okay I'm everywhere to the Lady Gaga one
everything except for Roanoke except my
Roanoke second I am excited to see what
the next one is going to be about I
exclusively have the main titles for the
new season of American Horror Story oh
my god you can only see it here Owen I'm
not here at all on the FX network
YouTube know where I do not shine this
video let's check this shizzle out never
never
[Music]
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay that was was not a trailer for it
that's how the opening yeah yeah I
thought I'm like for some reason I
thought I'm gonna be Taylor yeah I see
this is actually the very first video
we've ever done in your channel
I know welcome to your new age all right
I get the sense that they filmed the
opening sequence like long before
everything or like very separate yeah
yeah okay I like they've redesigned it
you like they've redesigned the song
yeah that was super creepy I had like a
sec at the carnival a vibe yeah like
circus II combined with one of patriotic
March yeah because there's a lot of
patriotic references in this that's
creepy in itself you know the left and
the right that's like the only thing I
know about this season for sure is that
they're going to borrow a lot from the
recent election cycle in America but I
was actually surprised to see a trump
mask in a Hillary map I know that was
really surprising I was I was halfway
expecting to see what's her name the
redhead with this thing know which
redhead one I think they don't they
probably do and maybe i'm is really this
perfect chick but got a lot of [ __ ] for
like holding the trial ready with this
thing how did i know how can you not
that's the most intriguing thing to me
about this and they keep saying we're
not going to exactly use these things
we're not going to reference from
specifically which is not the case here
but we even a show sounds like a lie I'm
very curious to see what their take on
this becomes because as a definitive
title as a theme conjures up more than
just the election absolutely there was a
lot of weird little references like I
almost felt like a Freddy Krueger figure
at the end yeah yeah we gotta me like by
the carousel area and you know like old
horror and stuff like that us all cult
kind of stuff oh yeah definitely one
it's funny to me to have this carousel
motif yeah a lot of fans that look kind
of carnival
that's interesting that means it's
because now I'm thinking about freakshow
yeah
what is the contrast is there going to
be any crossover because yeah they're
well they're you know there has been
some crossover in the season and I last
saw with the Lady Gaga that like oh but
I want to say too much about it because
they're famous
yeah are you episode tota I don't know
my history with American horror stories
I've seen the first two seasons and like
a few episodes of all the rest really
like a lot of clowns a lot of like my
hums creep a lot of people have yeah and
their patriotic colors that's true yet
point huh
we've got triple phobia look at so many
like little hold and even death why
isn't he crawling out of stuff and like
I like the image - of the guy in the
hazmat suit with a gas mask like I'd
almost remind me - crazy yeah I know you
were catching a free Kruger vibe off I
was so like they pulled from that genre
a little bit well hey the American dream
whoa it's always hard to tell what this
is going to become an American Horror
Story is a very divisive TV yeah but
this even though it's just an opening
credit sequence this actually makes me
really intrigued more so than a few of
the past seasons even seasons that have
had like themes that directly appeal to
me this seems fascinating in a whole
other way because now they're really
gonna bring it into the present it seems
like this looks like it's gonna be a fun
season I need to catch up dude you do
you like I do because I mean Evan Peters
with blue hair I got to be ready for
that going down I mean right I wasn't
sold on Evan Peters in the first season
so much but let me open to my super [ __ ]
I mean I forget you love at the 8th I
met it yeah I just scanned what is sexy
about paint yeah that wasn't your night
so no real well no no wha hit that
comment box let us know are you looking
forward to American Horror Story cult
what are your thoughts let's hear that
you can subscribe to the real rejects
crime hits that notifications OH
and get notified every time a review or
a video comes out I need a star you got
to check out a neatest Stars channel if
you haven't already I haven't already I
shame on ya patreon
great come check out patreon Spreadshirt
alas page scribe do we need a star I
think you said that already but thank
you for the you know reiteration just
anytime scribe to me I am Gordon
elegance